I'm Michael from Vsauce one Kevin from
Vsauce 2 and i'm jake from vsauce3 we
are here in front of a box full of the
100 most googled questions according to
mondo Voe we're gonna see if we can
answer them without Google here we go
[Music]
the hundredth most googled question you
guys ready how many calories are in a
banana ooh I'm gonna go with like 30
whoa
we are not licensed nutritionist so much
easier question what is the meaning of
life 42 Google might even say like did
you mean 42 yes how to cook quinoa easy
you put it in water that's boiling fluff
with a fork it doesn't say so that's a
lot how to get rid of blackheads I'm not
a dermatologist I would recommend just
letting them live their life the
dermatologist I would reckon how many
ounces in a gallon 64 64 M double it how
to get rid of acne do hot water to put
on the soap wash it again with hot water
then use cold water to close the pores
how to draw a dog can I eat this banana
by the way just with a new cow and some
paint thank you
this is a nice pin Kevin's a Kevin does
like a work of art your dog looks like a
cave painting how to make money fast
oh I click here how to last longer in
bed foreplay distract yourself ok
communicate whatever I don't think this
is very PG how many people are in the
world a lot how old is Justin Bieber 22
March come on Jake I know anything all
right how to save money don't spend it
put it in a bank Melissa don't trust
banks in which case put it in your
address next up we have how to start a
business started fire how tall is Kevin
Hart 5 4 how many MB and a GB it should
be what a thousand 1024 I mean about
that how to delete facebook account the
old days they used to be what is like
your security setting thing then there
was like delete profile there's a bunch
of do you want to and you say yes
how to hack facebook account get access
to their email address you can say I
forgot the password he said oh it's
social engineer them how to take a
screenshot well this depends on your
device if an iPhone you press a vine
down button and the sleep button at the
same time or the power button the same
time if it's on a Mac I believe it's
control option for PC you press print
screen and then you have to copy and
paste that into Photoshop or paint
something like that if it's on the
Android device it depends on the piece
of hardware that you're using Samsung as
a different variation than LG yeah
it's all very intricate here's a good
one how to gain weight calorie dense
foods would be best just drink a
vegetable oil what is the time 3:14 they
had to Google what time it was
what are they googling on that doesn't
have a clock that's the question how
much house can I afford thinking about a
house as like a measurement is I can
afford a kitchen like in one living room
nothing else yet oh I think Spencer
should not exceed 36% good ok how many
Ounces are in a liter 32 how to write a
cover letter dear insert name here yeah
what up why is the sky blue Michael I
know you know this but light from the
Sun scatters off of the atmosphere the
longer wavelengths scattered less the
shorter ones scatter more including the
color blue there's an even more to that
because there should be a lot more
purple and indigo but our eyes see red
and purple together with the same cone
instead we we make it a light blue other
animals might see a different color sky
how many centimeters in an inch about
2.4 how long to boil eggs oh this is
like they bring it to a boil 12-minute
hand well eights for a soft boy that's
my life it's a Harmon Romani how many
teaspoons in a tablespoon three all
right who sings this song how many
countries in the world it really depends
195 how to solve a Rubik's Cube watching
tutorials on YouTube what time is it in
Hawaii three hours behind Los Angeles so
it's like my day in there what is the
temperature like 68 what is the temp the
temp is the person who's too
when is Labor Day January 23rd 1986 my
mom went into labor on that day and I
came out 4th of September when is
Memorial Day May what time is it in
Australia what are the 16 hours it
depends what part of Australia are
talking about because Melbourne and
Perth are in different time zones how to
make money online create a YouTube
channel GoFundMe how many days until
Christmas oh I don't even actually know
what day it is what does HMU me get me
up each of you how many days in a year
well done dear what is daylight saving
time man cool how to tie a bow time
YouTube videos how to write a check I'm
just gonna write pay the owner Jake
Roper Jake I present to you this check
for a lot of money what time is sunset 8
how many ounces in a cup 8 what time is
the Super Bowl 6:30 Eastern how many
tablespoons in a cup ah it's a lie
how to make slime well guess what
subscribe to Vsauce is curiosity box and
you'll get 2 colors of slime how to make
love it's something that you demonstrate
every day through many different ways of
appreciating in another person's
existence how to make french toast red
eggs and then serum what is your name my
name is Michael how to use snapchat it's
very unintuitive I actually had to have
a younger person explain it to me
because I just so mad oh maybe that's
step one how do you spell I mean you're
pretty much there how to have sex
that's me googling then alright how many
ounces in a quart 4 times 8 is 32 how
many grams in a pound up brothers do
material ones are tough how to make a
beat son what you got to do is you get
some yeast you get some flour you get
some water warm water you put into a
bowl put a little olive oil on the dough
put it in the fridge cover it in plastic
wrap take it out after it's risen put it
down on the table with a little bit more
flour there so doesn't stick roll it out
turn into a circle put your pasta sauce
on top of it you hopefully made yourself
put cheese if you're not lactose
intolerant whatever toppings you want
throw it in the oven cook it at some
degree from his set amount of time and
you're done
to draw a rose ooh
Rose is much harder than I thought that
book maybe looks more like a rose that's
more of a carnation I think I drew an
artichoke how to get rid of bed bugs you
can't how old am i how old is Google
Google is what 98 97 yeah what time is
it in London
825 34 pretty close how many days till
Christmas 235 yeah how many cups in a
gallon huh four cups in a quart four
quarts in a gallon sixteen cups and
again how to take a screenshot on a Mac
it's control up on shore how to delete
Instagram account go to setting yeah go
to settings and then the probably delete
10 are you sure you want to delete how
to boil eggs you heat the water up until
it's boiling 12 minutes 12 we've been
told 10 to 12 good how to download
videos from YouTube Bob you shall not
you shall not it's like you talk it's
like Gandalf you shall not download
video K what is the weather today it's
nice and sunny a little bit cool where
is my phone where is my I think I think
mine's in it I said on silent over there
is it going to rain today no no I don't
think so how to lose belly fat leave it
in a cab I lose everything
how old is Hillary Clinton 62 no what
does smh mean hey what time is it in
California 12 12 32 that way how many
feet in a mile
5,000 5,000 142 how many grams in an
audience
goodness gracious how to make money buy
a printer or scanner that's old enough
that they don't have a security feature
installed and then you scan the money
you know Photoshop won't let you do that
when we were young whoa poetry when we
were young how to make pancakes by some
this quick yeah by Bisquick pour oil and
water in there and then you thing whip
it around pour it onto a nonstick pan
flip it then you're done where are you
now where are you now in your life
Michael I don't know I don't want to
know my dad only gave me one piece of
advice ever he said don't peek too soon
I could die today I might never die we
might discover immortality before then
point is where am I now is undefined
that was a good
how to lose weight fast gastric bypass
plans
how old is Donald Trump he's 72 70 Wow
how to screenshot on Mac visit us twice
how to download YouTube videos
you literally morally can't how to get
pregnant
ah when two people follow and can I run
it yes what is my IP address
check your router we actually featured
that in a dong how to find your IP
address oh and my ID my IP was a pretty
good check that out 13 what is Father's
Day for June June 7th well yeah how many
weeks in a year 52 - how many ounces in
a gallon golly
didn't wear D answer yeah 128 128 top 10
question 10 how many ounces in a pound
it's 16 when is Mother's Day oh that's
me it's a Sunday in May
yeah my mom's birthday's in two days by
the way love you mom happy birthday how
many ounces in a cup
eight how to lose weight better size
what song is this John Deere ages 411
[Laughter]
can you run it that's a long threat and
you run it can you run it how to tie a
tie
oh yeah wait hey I don't actually know
the name of it it's just the one way I
know how to tie a tie when you tighten
it tighten that baby whatever how to
register to vote it's a really good well
depends on the state really google it
yeah what time is it
348 question number one what is my IP is
it static is it dynamic
we don't really know so as we can tell
the world is full of questions how many
of them did we get right a bunch hey I
was like you know my goal for today is
to get a bunch